man hat ja immer über die
gleichberechtigung in der industrie ich
persönlich wenn ehemalige fußballerinnen
und aktuelle sportjournalistin und sport
moderatorin und sage im sport einfach an
im fußball ist es noch viel schlimmer
denn 2 prozent nur der
geschäftsführenden der
bundesliga-vereine sind tatsächlich
weiblich anfang 22 lag der frauenanteil
in den vorständen der dax-unternehmen
bei
18,1 und im fußball liegt der anteil an
frauen die in den führungspositionen
arbeiten gerade mal bei zwei prozent das
ruft natürlich jetzt alle freunde der
frauenquote hier auf den plan dennoch
sage ich bitte nicht keine frauenquote
quote wir brauchen mehr frauen mit eiern
heißt mehr frauen die tatsächlich diesen
sport lieben die auch etwas verändern
wollen und nicht frauen die einfach auf
diese positionen gesetzt werden weil es
eine quote gibt wir könnten ja auch
unfähige männer die mit sicherheit auf
diesen positionen sitzen zunächst mit
einem vielleicht bisschen fähigeren
frauen besitzen ich bin ganz ganz großer
fan der tote ich glaube auch nicht dass
wir eine brauchen ich glaube dass wir
all diese frauen haben die diese jobs
können die lust auf diese jobs haben und
warum kommen sie nicht auf diese jobs
weil sie verhindert werden und ich
wünschte wir bräuchten keine quote ich
will mir das würde sich regulieren da
schauen wir auf die letzten 50 jahren
wenn du die zahlen 1 2 prozent in
führungspositionen
wenn du nicht weisst nicht ganz der
ganze sport das muss man daher auch dazu
sagen derzeit noch mal separat zu
betrachten der fußball ist in der ganzen
sport noch mal speziell zu betrachten
dennoch sage ich oder ist meine
vermutung es gibt tatsächlich auch nicht
so viele frauen die das unbedingt wollen
genauso sehr wie vielleicht ein mann die
dann auch den mut haben das laut
auszusprechen und das ist leider auch
unsere geschichte geschuldet weil wir
frauen generell so erzogen wurden
niemals zu laut zu sein niemals zu
fordernd zu sein sie hat daher
schiefgegangen
der stelle bestätigen ich kenne ein paar
bau hat er ganz toll gemacht habe das
brauchen wir ja auch also genau solche
frauen brauchen wir im fußball wir
brauchen frauen die den fußball lieben
die diesen sport lieben die da auch
etwas bewegen wollen die die frauen auch
nach vorne bringen wollen und sie sich
dann auch dafür einsetzen und bitte
nicht frauen die auf positionen gesetzt
werden nur aufgrund der quote weil damit
tut man uns frauen keinen gefallen und
der fußball ist komplex und da braucht
es definitiv kompetente leute definitiv
auch kompetente frauen die muss man
finden aber ich sage es gibt noch nicht
so viele noch eine argumentation die
höre ich sonst nur von weißen alten
männern dann ist eine argumentation die
mich wahnsinnig überrascht aus dem mund
einer frau denn natürlich gibt es diese
frauen noch mal und zwar in allen
bereichen das ist das klassische
argument das klassische verzeichnet
macho argument dass man dann habe ich
mir jetzt eine eigene maximalgebot
würdest du die quote angesetzt weil das
ist immer ganz spannend also würde deine
frau wurde beginnen welcher größe kann
hier so gar nicht genau sagen ich bin da
keine er rechne im mensch der die jetzt
ausrechnen könnte wie mir ist einfach
nur wichtig dass wir es festsetzen dass
wir morgens in diese positionen bringen
denn ich glaube und da geht es eben um
diese freiwilligkeit und die müssen wir
suchen und so weiter werden wir frauen
installiert haben und selbst wenn du gar
nicht die beste frau hasst für die
position dann kannst du damit rechnen
dass andere frauen nach aber da die rhön
alive wir holen dagegen wenn das hier
eröffnen wir legen auch die gleiche
frage jetzt hier sah man immer nach
wieder einmal fürchterlich patricia
diesen das mittel passe ich richtig
deswegen frage ich es lieber einen alten
weisen mann und zweier boss paar ich
hoffe es ist in ordnung dass sich die
anreise bezeichnet für mich der weise
ich würde gerne von ihnen wissen wie sie
denn zu dem thema stehen
da ganz so als mal nur fehler machen
sie bekommt zwischen die schultern und
sagt ich habe keinem zeigt im moment ist
jetzt an den satz gehört wenn ich sie
kurz unterbrechen darf heutzutage ist es
auch nicht leicht ein mann zu sein das
stimmt ja anscheinend
ja ich hätte es nicht besser sagen
können dürfte er bekannte sich zu hause
mit fünf frauen zusammenleben ist nicht
einfach aber es geht
und ich meine wir leben wenn man sich
die runde hier anschaut dann haben heute
die kriminalität gesetzt
hat muss natürlich sagen eingesetzt
wenn ich das richtig im kopf habe
christian seifert der hat ja wirklich
aus der dfl was gemacht hat den dienst
quittiert und ich glaube er hat eine
nachfolgerin wenn ich richtig informiert
bin mit
ochsen genau aber sie ist doch
garantiert nicht an die spezielle dfl
gekommen weil sie jetzt eine quote
erfüllen muss weil die nächste besetzung
eine frau sein muss sondern weil sie
einfach nicht ist und genau ich bin kein
anhänger bin kein anhänger der kot und
ich glaube es ist eine frage der zeit
ist eine frage der zeit wenn er das es
als ganz selbstverständlich angesehen
wird dass auch führungsposition im sport
im männerdominierten
fußballsport
ganze wie ganz selbstverständlich
spitzenpositionen entschuldigung eine
frage der zeit wie viele jahre sollen
wir denn da noch warten also noch mal 50
jahre ist es ja nicht so dass ich so
wahnsinnig viel bewegt hat in den
vergangenen jahren als würde ich jetzt
gerne aus leiten wir können aber zum
amerikanischen fußballverband schauen er
hat der jüngste gerade gesagt dass auch
die preisgelder
angehoben werden sollen und ich finde
schon dass es gut wäre die preisgelder
im frauenfußball genauso hoch anzusetzen
wie im männerfußball
das wäre für mich gelebte
gleichberechtigung
wir sollten uns dafür einsetzen dass
eben an dieser stelle auch für gute
hochwertige trainingsbedingungen all das
was dazugehört gibt dann brauchen dann
nämlich auch diese quotendiskussion
nicht dann kann er hier bleiben und muss
nicht den fußball trainieren
so sagt er seien zu sprung zur seite
springen ich komme ja aus berge
schlagbaren ich war jahrelang im
präsidium von ssg 09
und wir hatten ja deutschlands
erfolgreichste fußball frauenmannschaft
über jahre hinweg zunächst war der
frauenfußball verboten
dann wurde er erlaubt und dann suchte
man eine nationalmannschaft und da hat
man unsere mannschaft aus bergisch
gladbach in nationaltrikots gesteckt
nach taiwan geschickt und die haben
zweimal den weltpokal gewonnen als dann
die richtige deutsche nationalmannschaft
der frauen an den start gingen mit acht
oder neun spielerinnen aus welche stadt
das erste tor wurde von einer nachbarin
geschossen von loris krise wurden die
worte bei uns um die ecke um gab ist ein
café sowie als preis
die zeit da hat sich geändert aber es
stimmt es gibt immer noch eine grosse
differenz
real madrid gegen barcelona wurde der
zuschauer rekord gebrochen bei den
frauen es waren über 91.000 zuschauern
stadion und das zeigt es bewegt sich
definitiv etwas auch im fußball und es
geht auch ohne quote und ohne zwang
regeln ja was dass airbus back sagt das
habe ich mal nachgeguckt das war 1989
das war ein kaffeeservice mit blauen und
roten blüten wie die spielerinnen
bekommen fortschrittlich damit aber wenn
wir uns angucken deswegen bin ich auch
bei meinen beiden männlichen kollegen
wir sind alle dafür dass die zahlungen
ich weiß nicht wie realistisch das ist
aber angeglichen werden die letzte
statistik die ich davon gefunden haben
das im jahr 2018 das dann dass eine frau
im profifußball in der ersten liga im
durchschnitt
39.000 euro im jahr verdient das
verdient ein bundesliga-spieler im
durchschnitt an einem spieltag auch
nicht die wirtschaft die man sich eine
revanche gibt es doch auch die freie
wirtschaft würde ich jetzt mal absolut
das heißt es ja auch angebot und
nachfrage
das heißt ich könnte jetzt mal patricia
fragen als frauenquote für den sport
fussball wie oft schaust du den
frauenfußball ich muss sagen ich schau
frauenfußball männerfußball aber schon
und dementsprechend angebot und
nachfrage wo es dann nicht erst mal um
auch das geld zu zahlen für gehälter für
preise er muss doch erst mal das
interesse am frauenfußball hoch sein ist
auch wie in allem im leben angebot und
nachfrage
vielleicht weniger in den gremien wären
finden sie wege den frauenfußball auch
so zu erziehen dass er auch häufiger
gesendet wird formen zu finden wo man
sagt okay das schaue ich mir an aber
wenn nur eine riege da ist das war jedes
mal gegen mein geschlecht die sagte
interessiert uns nicht oder nur pro
forma dann komme ich ja auch nicht da
hin dass zu entwickeln also das finde
ich ein ganz wichtigen hinweis und das
ist das warum wir euch männer darin
brauchen auch dann mit ihrem wagen
wichtig dass wir gemeinsam auch öffnen
kann er deswegen auch total schade dass
hier so wenige männer jetzt gerade in
dieser wilden diskussion zu wort kommen
dabei sagt wähler genau das ist
wir lassen euch mehr zeit zum reden aber
das ist genau das was ich das selbst
entwickelt dass man schaut her wir
frauen auch in solche positionen bringen
desto mehr frauen werden nach brasilien
habe man darf man darauf sein hätte für
das thema von herrscher ganz
abschließend sagen man muss ja das
problem an der wurzel packt man muss die
wurzel ausreißen dafür braucht man auch
die männer dafür braucht man keine quote
denn wenn man nur die blätter rausreißt
und das wäre die quote anwachsen der
immer wieder nach was physisches
valentina einen dürfen sterblichen löwe
sich direkter schlusswort geholt